let's let's just try one more caller
here we'll go to the 7 7 8 area code and
see what we get caller from 7 7 8 you
might be the last caller so let's make
it good who's this hey listen well I
don't want to interrupt we're not on
speakerphone are we no boy okay all
right let's let's go with it
should i oh I just wonder if there's a
way for callers to know how many people
are in line I'm having a hard time all
right can you can we turn him up or can
you speak up a little bit what was the
question I was wondering if callers
could know how many callers are in line
let me call in oh there's no way now I
wish I had a better answer there's
really no way I mean like right now
there's 15 people holding there's no way
but you're on now so like did you have a
question yeah okay so on separate
occasions I've heard you say that you've
had disagreements with Sam Harris and
you had many cruces of Sam Harris there
just wondering what those are yeah so I
mean listen I I think that there's some
stuff that Sam Harris does in terms of
extrapolating carefully cherry-picked
data to get to some conclusions about
for example the uniqueness of Islam in
the context of religious extremism that
I don't agree with so like I'm often
called an islamaphobe for my criticisms
of Islam and at the same time I find
some of Sam Harris's conclusions about
the unique connection that he finds
between Islam and terror I think like
for example what's missing from a lot of
sam Harris's statements about Islam and
terror today is that historically and
he'll say I've also been a critic of
Christianity historically there was a
period where algebra and astronomy and
the foundations of so much of science
were coming from the world of Islam
well it was Christianity that was just
disproportionately in
involved in terror and violence so I
think that I'm on the I'm on the the
side of Sam Harris in that we should
identify sources of terror in 2018 and
figure out how to curb those I am in
disagreement with Sam Harris with the
idea that there's anything particularly
unique to the problem that is currently
being experienced between Islam and
terror and I think it's a sort of a
historical to make that argument okay
with that it orders their other subjects
I mean is there one you have in mind I
don't know a lot of curious if you had
any others in mind also when you had the
interview with Colin Moriarty I remember
you talking about a school of thought
where you know Colin was saying oh why
don't we just print more money it's that
the attack spending doesn't matter and
you were referring to a school of
thought where you could just keep
printing money in that the debt isn't
that concerning yeah so it's modern
monetary theory and basically we did a
couple interviews on that with Pavlina
Chernova and stephanie kelton the idea
is not that just printing money has no
effect but that if you're printing some
predetermined amount of money right not
an unlimited amount of money if it's
being used in economically stimulative
ways the benefit of having printed that
money will outdo any inflationary or
negative effects if you just print money
and give it to rich people then that's
not what they're suggesting but that if
you're printing money for the right
reasons it actually can be a net gain to
the economy and won't create you know
like an inflation spiral how's your love
life
it's great thank you great thank you all
right thank you very much appreciate I
don't know if that was trolling I really
don't know if that was trolling I like
how it started as a live call about live
calls yeah it was it went it was very
meta then it went into other stuff and
then it went to my love life
so yeah very good a call all right six
one seven eight three zero 4750 is the
number I do apologize there are 17
people holding and we're not going to be
able to get to you this week but we will
take calls again